today we've got a really big project
it's cleaning organizing and donating
things that I'm no longer going to wear
out of my closet so I just recently
partnered with savers in Value Village
to bring you guys this very very
important message one that I absolutely
had no idea was even a problem the
amount of clothing that people throw
away instead of donating is just
astronomical one cotton t-shirt takes
seven hundred gallons of water to make
seven hundred gallons I can't even
picture what that even looks like so
challenging people to save water with
one simple act donate your shirts or if
you're planning on buying a shirt see if
there's a thrift each one that you might
want to get instead and if you're not in
the market for a new t-shirt you might
have some old shirts playing around so
before you throw them away please think
about donating them I give a shirt they
sent me this shirt and it's actually a
thrifted shirt and it's screen printed
with eco-friendly screen print of I gave
a shirt let's get started all this
closet baby hm what you done looks like
I'm on my own with this one
it's time for the final reveal so here's
what I did it might not look like
there's a huge difference but I promise
you if you saw the before and afters so
go back to school at the beginning and
you'll see there's a huge difference if
that's not enough these bags should be a
sure sign the things are looking up
this is supposed to taking you two hours
that's what I estimated it's dark out it
took way more than two hours for more
information on this entire amazing
movement check out rethink reuse calm
you guys can find places where you can
donate your clothes you define places
that you can get other clothes that have
already been donated thank you guys so
much for watching this video I hope you
guys have a lovely day and I'm gonna go
donate the rest of the shirts actually
since it's dark out I'm gonna go put
them in my car and do that morning